is
dear friends i'm delighted to be with
you
and it is fitting that we start this new
year with
a one planet summit in paris talking
about biodiversity
because i believe 2021 will be the year
when the world turns over new leaf for
our planet
in a few months we the world will come
together in kunming
and this cup 15 for nature
must be like the cup 21 was for climate
and we need a paris style agreement to
go with it
global and game-changing
the stakes could not be higher and the
imperative
act could not be more compelling this is
about sustainable development
because thriving biodiversity can ensure
access to food water and energy
for billions of people this is about
equality
because we know that the effects of
nature loss
disproportionately affect poorer
and indigenous communities
this is about our security because
conflicts explode when more people
grapple
for less natural resources
and this is about our quality of life
because we need nature in our lives for
our physical and mental health
we all know the scale and the urgency of
the task ahead of us
this year and we see the changes in our
everyday lives
from more concrete blocks to less
wilderness and wildlife
to increasing temperatures and extreme
weather
and these worrying changes are different
sides of the same coin
in fact they mutually reinforce each
other
when we lose forests we don't just
lose green space or natural habitat
we lose a key ally in our fight against
climate change
when temperatures rise and nature
disappears
we suffer more natural disasters and
zoonotic diseases
we have spoken a lot about these links
between biodiversity loss and covet
but this is not the first last or
even most telling example think of how
one of the
deadliest outbreaks of ebola is thought
to have started with a young boy playing
next to a tree in a remote village in
guinea
a tree that had been infested by bats
who had been pushed towards the village
because 80 percent of forests in the
region had been destroyed
and we know the tragic repercussions
this had
and if we don't urgently act to protect
our nature
we may already be at the beginning of an
era
of pandemics but we can do something
about it
it needs concerted global action local
sustainable development
and just as we cooperate for our one
planet
we need each other for our one health
and this is why we will prioritize
research on one health
across horizon europe and let me be
clear
we will invest several hundred million
euros
over the next four years for research
on biodiversity animal health
emerging diseases and much more
it is why we will work closely with our
international partners on
research in the spirit of the preside
initiative launched by france and member
states
which the european commission welcomes
and it is also why we will bolster and
sponsor initiatives like the african-led
great green wall
i would like to congratulate the african
union and all
of the partners involved for bringing
a decades-old dream to life
we have already seen the difference it
can make stretching from senegal in the
west to
debut in the east it has helped restore
15 million hectares of degraded land in
ethiopia
and supported farmers in niger to
produce enough grain to feed an extra
2.5 million people a year
and this is why i say today we will
mobilize
even more than the 700 million euros per
year
already raised for the great green wall
project
the more partners and the more member
states join and invest
the more we can do and this is the
spirit of team europe and i am
determined that we can do so much more
working with our african partners
this shows that turning over a new leaf
for nature all comes down to local
action
and global ambition this is why the
european green deal
we are stepping up own action and
ambition both
locally and globally our new
biodiversity
and farm to fork strategies will lead
the way
they set out the eu's ambitions to
protect indeed 30 percent of land and
sea areas
in europe and around the world
they will help us restore damaged rivers
and plant three billion trees by 2030.
will bring help and bring back to
pollinators
to agriculture lands and reduce the use
and risk of harmful pesticides
and the new greener common agricultural
policy
will help us protect livelihoods and
food security
while we protect our nature and our
climate
but we know we need to do more being a
major economy
and a trading superpower comes
with responsibilities and it is our duty
to ensure
that our single market does not
drive deforestation in local communities
in other parts of the world
and this is why later this year
we will propose new legislation
to minimize the risk of products linked
to global deforestation
being placed on the european market
so europe is ready to lead the way and i
hope others will join us in that effort
dear friends this sums up the eu's
approach
in this historic year for nature
we will lead by ambition and action
at home and we will do everything we can
to bring
as many partners on board with us
this is why we will work to broker an
ambitious agreement in kunming
and it is why we will support
initiatives like the great green wall
let's make sure that we turn over this
new leaf together thanks very much
to all the participants and thanks very
much to you mr president sherry manuel
merci beaucoup
[Music]
african
[Music]
you